hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about
how to stay motivated while you're
learning how to
code this is something that can be so so
tricky and can really
be the thing that stands in the way
between achieving
that end goal that you set for yourself
and not
so let's get to it number one have a
study plan
it's not enough for you to just say you
know what i will
get to it when i get to it i'll learn
and do this new project or do this new
lesson
when i'm free no sit down figure
out when you want to reach your end goal
first figure out what you want that
integral to be
is it a new job is it being accepted
into a boot camp is it just
creating let's say five portfolio
projects what do you want the end goal
to be
and in what timeline do you want to get
there
once you figure these two things out sit
down
and figure out what your study plan
should be to get you there
how many hours a week a day should you
devote
to studying to learning to developing
to get to that end goal by x amount of
months years etc
and if you see that oh shoot i'm trying
to get here
three months from now and i because i
have a full-time job and i'm a student
at a university x y and z
i won't be able to sit down for more
than 50 minutes a day
and if i do that i'm not gonna get here
by three months from now xyz
then adjust adjust what your timeline is
figure out where in your schedule you
can cut certain things
back and just go from there but
seriously have a study plan because it's
going to be so much easier
to say oh it's tuesday at 2 p.m
that means we're learning something new
today and sitting down and doing it
being consistent with that
is going to be a lot more helpful rather
than oh i guess i'm free
now like no let's let's not do it number
two this is going to sound a little
weird
but follow coding accounts follow
accounts for learning to code
or accounts of actual developers
doing the thing that you want to see
yourself doing and the reason this is
important is because
when you distract yourself most of us
distract ourselves by either
tv or social media when you go
on social media and you start scrolling
and you start seeing
people doing the thing that you're
hoping to get to it's going to motivate
you to put that phone away
and pick up your laptop and start
learning and continuing on
that journey is going to help so much
just helping you stay
inspired really and there are really
great accounts out there both
for teaching just going over certain
basics and certain fundamentals and
things like that
and also more of an influencer type but
still
staying in that development world and i
think that can be extremely extremely
useful
you can follow me that can be your first
step follow me on instagram
at the black female engineer but yeah
start doing that as well number three
share your accomplishments this is
something that actually
i'm very bad at i when i have a new goal
or a new project in all of this i tend
to keep it very hush-hush not wanting to
keep anybody updated on what i'm doing
how i'm doing at the speed i'm doing it
and all of that until i get to my end
goal
a lot of people didn't even know i
became a developer
until after i got the job and it was
just like wait weren't you just in
my finance class like it was the
funniest thing but
for me that's just how i operate however
don't shy away
from celebrating your accomplishments
with other people post it on instagram
post it on linkedin
say today i'm halfway through the 100
days of coding
today i just completed so and so project
check it out on using this link share
your accomplishments because one it's
great to just
get that positive feedback of people
cheering you
on saying way to go and it just makes
you feel good and more motivated
to keep on going and two it also helps
other people know that you're now on
this journey
and when it comes time to job hunt and
all of this
you're not going to surprise people by
saying hey i need a job in software
development meanwhile they
thought you were still an accountant way
back when so it helps a lot
for multiple reasons number four this
kind of goes with number three
and that's tell your parents about it
tell your parents or
somebody you love and trust and
that'll help you in this process because
something i've always said
is if you want something to get done
tell your parents about it
because i'm just a person who if i tell
my parents about it now it has to get
done
now i have to get through it because i
never want to be the person or the
daughter that
just says things but never falls through
with them that's just something that
is not me at all and so when i do
cross that threshold of saying oh i'm
going to do this i'm going to be this
i'm going to accomplish
this you best believe is going to be
accomplished
and so figure out who that person is in
your life is it your parents
is it your loved one is it your
significant other doesn't matter who it
is could be your mailman
doesn't matter who it is with someone
who you trust
who you love and respect and tell them
about your goals tell them
you want to pursue development you want
to
be in so and so company work for google
work for facebook
tell them your goals your hopes and now
when it's time to study and it's time to
do x y and z
you have this feeling of and not in a
bad way but you have this feeling of
like i can't let people down
because they're rooting for me and of
course
if you figure out coding and development
is not for you then
of course leave it behind and figure out
what is for you but if you know it's for
you
it still can be difficult to push
yourself
to go towards this thing to continue
on the study plan and so having the back
of your mind like
these people are rooting for me i don't
want to let them down it can help as
long as
it stays healthy because it can also
turn unhealthy very quick so let's make
sure we're staying in that healthy
mindset and number five know your why
know the bigger picture of why you're
doing this is because
you want to reach financial freedom by a
certain age you want to own a home by a
certain age
you want to simply enjoy your work
and be a part of a development team
and be a part of what touches so many
people every single day and that's
developing and coding and just in
general technology
what is your why for me it was a mix of
these things
it was partly the financial freedom part
but a lot of it
was itch this was the first thing that
had ever excited me in terms of
a potential career and i wanted to
chase that to and see where it goes
and when i look at the world we live in
especially in the united states
where there are so many white men
in the development roles this often
creates problems when it comes to
inclusive
coding practices what i mean by that is
you can
sometimes end up with software and end
up with apps that
aren't thinking about the minority party
and i wanted to be a part of the
solution i wanted to be
a part of striving towards something
better
and so overall that's my why and your
wine needs to be something that's
large enough where even on your worst of
days where you think
you're not good enough where you think
you're just not
achieving the things you want to and
everything because it will happen
hopefully not so much but it will happen
every now and then and you need to find
a way to overcome it
the way you overcome it is by thinking
about your
why so figure out what your why is right
now
write it down somewhere pick up a
notebook whatever
write it down and whenever you are
doubting yourself whenever you are
feeling unmotivated
feeling like this is not the path for
you look at what you wrote
there and please never think that you
are not a person who can be
in this career just because the people
around you don't
look like you if that is the case it was
the case for me
and often that's what would be that's
what would
make me feel discouraged making me feel
not so great during this process but
remembering my why is what got me
through this so
there you go everybody my five tips for
staying motivated
during this coding journey during your
transition
into software development i hope this
helped if it did please leave a like
comment below and don't forget
to subscribe but i'll see you all later
bye